there was sheer relief that the woman
responsible for their son's death had
finally been held accountable answer
kulas pleaded guilty to causing the
death of Harry Dunn by careless driving
his mum promised she'd get him Justice
it's done I'm done
the white had lifted off my shoulders as
I felt like I could I could breathe
Mrs sakulas a former U.S spy appeared at
the old bayley via video link from
Washington she left the UK in 2019
claiming diplomatic immunity after a
collision with Harry near RAF Croton in
northamptonshire an American
intelligence base Harry's family took
their fight to the White House even
lobbying president Trump for help but
the U.S refused to extradite her
the judge urged Mrs sakulas to attend
the sentencing in person but conceded
that there was no order she could make
to compel her to do so she also said
that any sentence that she passed was
unlikely to be enforceable while Mrs
sakulas remains outside the UK
Harry's family has never had control of
this drawn-out unprecedented process Mrs
takulas will decide what happens next
they say they just want her to do the
right thing
Lisa Dowd Sky News the Old Bailey